[Inaudible].
So as most of you know, I recently quit my job as a data scientist,
and I'm trying to get in to sweep and for sweep, if you want to get into sweep,
you have to do these coding interviews and these coding interviews.
They're not supposed to test you if you know how to code,
or if you're good at software engineering, they don't care about that.
Like coding is basically pure intelligence.
You're testing your pure intelligence, your IQ,
you don't actually care if you can do the actual job,
or if they think that you can do, you know, build their infrastructure.
What they care about is if you could like reverse a linked list or solve any of
those coding problems.
And I want to stress that these coding problems are just IQ tests.
They're not meant to show them how good you are at building infrastructure or
anything.
So I just want to tell people who aren't initiated in this suite interview
process, just so that you guys get some context,
like basically someone with no software engineering skills
can pass these interviews because it's kind of like a math test, you know,
and I'm trying to do that anyways.
That's a wake up and I didn't think of a transition, but, um,
here's an ad before we continue.
I just want to say that this video is sponsored by Skillshare.
Now they have a great promo going on.
If you sign up using the link on the description,
because they will give you two months of premium for free,
and here's a little secret most courses on there,
you could definitely finish in less than two months.
Premium membership gives you access to all their classes in communities,
and you can learn anything from design, business coding,
and even data science skill share is a perfect place to keep your mind
fresh and keep growing by learning a ton perfect for your new year goals.
Now 2019 is a year of growth and Skillshare is a perfect place to do that.
Skillshare is super affordable with an annual subscription of less than $10.
So I took a couple of classes and I was pleasantly surprised by one of their
classes. It's actually a data science class taught by Frank Kane and Oh,
he's an ex Amazon employee. And it was pretty, pretty good. Like I was very,
very impressed because the thing that's great about his class was it was
actually fully comprehensive.
It taught you from the basics of like Python to teaching how to do linear
regression, to like k-means clustering. It teaches you everything. Unlike,
you know,
a lot of other data science classes where they're just kind of like vague and
they're just talking about certain things. This one actually teaches you.
Step-by-step on how to become a data scientist.
It's basically what data science boot camps teach you.
And you can learn all of that using that course, which is really good. Anyways,
the first 500 people to click on the link in the description,
we'll get two months of premium membership for free,
and then you can take any classes you want. So check it out.
Yeah. Thank you.
In case you don't know what I did. I,
I snapped my fingers and my facial hair went away. Wait, let me show you.
See facial hair
clean.
Truly.
The only reason I shave is for this video because I haven't stepped outside.
In like weeks.
So as I was saying, I'm basically coding all day every day,
by the way,
I just want to say maybe not a really good idea to quit your job before
getting the offer. So, so yeah,
don't do what I did cause like the unemployment life, you know, it's killing me,
you know,
I'm so disgusting and unmotivated,
you know, it's just like, I feel like, uh,
basically it's just really hard to motivate yourself when you don't have a job.
So I wake up at like 1:00 PM nowadays. Like Holy,
it really shortens my day. Right.
And then all I do is try to solve these coding interviews and Holy
crap, man, don't get in really hard nowadays. Yeah.
I procrastinate like a lot and I don't even,
I don't even wear proper clothes anymore. Cause you know,
I don't need to go out and I start doing like really weird.
[Inaudible].
And I have to cook for myself now because from all these years working for Fang
companies, you just become a man child. You know, I'm a big man child.
I have no idea how to cook. So because of that, making food and eating food,
it takes super long. Right.
And then all that time I could have used for like the coding.
So I started wearing an Apple watch because I bought one because I'm
rich. Then,
then I realize I don't even want an Apple watch.
Like I hate watches. I hate wearing watches. It brings no value to me.
It's useless. But I said to myself,
maybe it's because I didn't buy the latest version.
Maybe that's why I think it's useless.
Like I didn't buy the ed mess watch because of that. It's useless.
So I think the idea is that I had to spend more money to make it
useful, but I am trying to make use of it now,
but I'm kind of embarrassed to say, but like it's an,
it's an Apple, it's an Apple watch. Yeah.
I feel so ashamed saying it because like it's an older generation, I don't know.
I'm sorry to disappoint you guys,
but like I am trying to force myself to exercise throughout this process because
I know that if you exercise then your brains going to be more sharp.
And if your brain's more sharp, you perform better in these coding interviews.
Right. So I try to complete those activity rings,
but I realize these things are not very well calibrated because um, Oh yeah.
For example, like one time I was in my room and I was, um,
I was watching pornography and I was also jacking off and by the way,
a Jack off of my F hand, which has also the hand I put my watch on, Oh yeah.
Jack off my left hand because you know,
you could use it right hand for the mouse so that I could skip through videos.
So it makes more sense. And it was,
and then suddenly my watch sends me this notification. It said,
I see you're working out. Do you want to record this workout session?
It thought I was doing the ellipticals, you know, like, like, like the,
this exercise. Right. So I thought it was a really,
really funny because I thought it was funny. It,
it's probably not that funny for you guys, but for me it was really funny.
Like you really had to be in the moment to appreciate it.
So basically what I ended up doing is I D I don't even need to exercise because
all I have to do is watch these videos and I get my 30 minutes worth of exercise
done every day. So I'm basically cheating.
Yeah. So basically coding, it reminds me of,
it really reminds me of school actually like during finals season where you're
just at home, sitting in your room, cramming, studying, practicing.
It really reminds me of that. But I suck, man. I really suck. Like,
I can't even do the easy problems.
I was never good at brainteasers, but yeah, just got to grind anyways.
I just wanted to update you guys on my life and what I'm doing. But, um, yeah.
I mean, I say all this, but Indiana, I kind of like it. Right.
It's very nostalgic, you know, it's, um, it feels, it feels nice.
Like when you finished problems,
when you do these problems and you get it right.
It feels like practicing for a math test or something very nostalgic.
Like basically what I do is I do this Pomodoro style thing, right? So like,
um, I solve one problem. I watch one episode of anime. I solve one problem.
I'll watch one episode. I solve one problem.
I watch five episodes of animate to finish the season.
If you're also like me doing the coding interview process, I just want to say,
yeah, don't give up. It's hard. It's hard for everyone, but it does get easier.
And, you know.
Say Alico today, keeps the unemployment the way.
So see ya.
[inaudible].